Yes,
authentic leftism is populous.
It is based in working class style,
working class language,
working class,
direct emotional openness and brushing
stuff.
Speech.
Okay.
Not this fancy,
contorted jargon of this udall leftist
of academe who are fraud.
These people,
these people who managed to manage to
rise to the top and at Berkeley and
Harvard and Princeton.
Okay.
Do you have any of these people are
radical?
They are career people.
Their corporate types.
Okay.
Then who like who succeeded in it?
They love the institutional contacts.
They know how to manipulate the
bureaucracy,
which is totally invaded in usurped.
Okay.
The academe everywhere.
These people are company polit players.
They could have done well in any,
any field.
They love to sit in endless committees.
They loved bureaucratic regulation and
so on.
There's not one,
not one leftist.
Okay.
And American academe raised his or her
voice against obscene growth.
Growth tuition costs which have
bankrupted a whole generation of young
people.
Not,
not one voice.
Okay.
To challenge that.
That that invasion by the bureaucrats.
Okay.
Actual fascist bureaucrats.
Well,
if we added the cancer risks.
Okay.
There are so many of them because the
faculty have completely lost any power
in American academia.
Okay.
It's us.
It's a scandal.
What has happened.
Okay.
And they deserve the president's
servitude that they're in right now.
Okay.
Because they never protested.
When I.
my first job at Bennington College,
Ninety,
76.
I was there when there was an uprising
by the faculty against encroachment,
by the board of trustees and the
president.
Okay.
And it was a huge thing.
It was,
it was.
It was reported on the New York Times
and so on.
And we.
And we pushed that precedent out.
Okay.
And,
and there's not been a single uprising
of mankind against,
against encroachment,
by the trustees and by the
administrations and all these decades.
Okay.
Pass them slaves.
Slaves.
They deserve their slavery.
Yep.
I couldn't agree more.
I thought the same thing about
university professors for a long time is
that they get exactly what they deserve
because they never stand up and say no.
And the fact that in the United States,
it's not quite as bad in Canada,
I wouldn't say,
but the fact that the students have been
essentially handed a bill of indentured
servitude here for the student loans is
absolutely beyond comprehension.
You know,
it seems to me that the bureaucracy has
basically conspired to determine how to
pick the pockets of the students' future
earnings.
Right?
And they do that by offering them an
extended adolescence with no quality
control,
something like that.
So it's a real bargain with the devil.
And,
and I told the abandonment of any kind
of education actually in history and
culture.
All right,
everybody got along with it.
That is the transformation into a
cafeteria kind of a menu.
Okay,
we can pick this course or that course
or this course without any kind of
guidance from the university about a
central core curriculum that teaches you
history and chronology and introduces
you to the basics,
right?
Because what are our professors are
prima donnas.
They can only teach and their little
areas.
So we have this total fragmentation and
the the,
the great art history survey courses are
being abandoned steadily because why?
Because graduate students are not
trained to see the great narratives or
the network because we are taught now
that narratives are fault.